Thanks to CuriosityStream for supporting PBS
Digital Studios.
We’ve made some improvements in recent decades
when it comes to how we power our society.
But by and large, our world still runs on
fossil fuels and nonrenewable energy.
And as long as we’re dependent on these limited
resources, we’ll need to design the most efficient
ways to harvest their energy.
But, that’s difficult, because the laws of
physics are not in our favor.
The fact is, you can’t make a super-efficient
system without any waste.
No matter how good of an engineer you are,
you can’t invent a perfect engine.
Why? It’s because of an energy crisis that
pervades our universe.
And it’s caused by entropy and the second
law of thermodynamics.
[Theme Music]
Since we’ve started designing engines, we’ve
constantly tried to improve them.
Our first engines weren't that efficient,
but we’ve come a long way since.
Take, for example, a heat engine.
Simply put, a heat engine is a machine or
system that converts heat into other forms
of energy.
And we can see how efficient they are, by
looking at their thermal efficiency.
The thermal efficiency of a heat engine is
the amount of useful work it can produce based
on the amount of heat that we give it.
So the more work we get out, the more efficiently
we use our fuel, and the less of it we need.
That’s why engineers are constantly trying
to make engines that are as thermally efficient
as possible.
Many of the internal combustion engines that you
find on the road are around 20% thermally efficient,
meaning that 20% of the heat that’s applied
n the engine actually does work.
There are some prototypes of automotive engines
that are 40% efficient.
And there’s even an air-cooled gas turbine
that delivers an over 61% combined cycle efficiency.
That’s impressive, but still it’s not
even close to 100%.
This seems to be our limit for how efficient
our engines can be – at least for now.
So what gives?
Why aren’t they any better?
Well, we’re restricted by thermodynamics.
You see, the first law makes it all seem pretty
simple.
If we can’t create or destroy energy, then any
change in energy that we have, must have an equal
and opposite change in energy somewhere else.
But in reality, it’s a bit more complicated
than that.
Based on the first law alone, you might
think that you could simply recycle energy
over and over again.
But while energy can’t be created or destroyed,
it can change into less useful or even unusable forms.
In fact, every real-world energy conversion has
some amount of energy that changes into a form
that’s unavailable to do work.
And this less-usable energy that’s lost
is usually heat.
But can’t we just convert that heat back
to work?
Well yes, but not entirely.
Heat can never be turned into another, work-performing
type of energy with 100% efficiency.
So every time you have a transfer of energy,
you’ll end up with some more “useless” energy.
For example, let’s say you have a hot bowl
of soup in a cold room.
Over time, the soup will cool off, and whatever
energy it loses, its surroundings will gain.
But you can’t take the energy from the cold
room and use it to heat the soup back up,
even though the exchange didn’t violate
the first law.
Or think of it in terms of electricity running
through a wire that goes to a radiator and
generates heat.
Electricity goes in, and heat comes out.
But if you tried heating the wire, you wouldn’t
get electricity back, even though, once again,
the first law isn’t violated.
This is where the second law of thermodynamics
comes in.
While the first law is all about the total
quantity of energy, the second law is all
the quality of energy.
The second law states that as energy is transferred
or transformed, more and more of it, is wasted.
It basically restricts the inter-conversion
between heat and work.
100% of the work that you put into a system
can be converted into heat, but 100% of heat
can’t be converted into work.
So to understand what this really means, let’s
look at a heat engine, an engine that converts
heat into energy that does work.
Say we put some heat energy into the engine.
The system will take the heat, go through
a process, and give us energy in the form
of work.
But some of the heat will always be released
at a cooler temperature as a secondary output.
No heat engine could operate without doing
this.
Basically, unless we’re only trying to get
heat, we’re going to have some amount of
inefficiency.
So how did we find any of this out?
Well, it all goes back to the work of two
great minds.
The first of these minds belonged to Sadi
Carnot, a French scientist who was probably
more brilliant than we’ll ever know.
Carnot came from a famous and influential
family.
His father was a mathematician and a military
engineer whose name would eventually be emblazoned,
along with those of other scientists, on the Eiffel Tower.
And Carnot followed in his father’s footsteps,
joining the French army corps of engineers in 1814.
But, then things got sticky.
His father had become minister of the interior,
under a fellow named Napoleon.
And after Napoleon met his literal Waterloo
and the monarchy was restored, Carnot’s father
was sent into exile.
But Carnot was allowed to stay – languish
is probably a better word.
He spent years inspecting army facilities
and writing reports that no one read.
Until, in 1819, he transferred back to Paris
and, out of curiosity, started attending lectures
on chemistry and physics.
And there, he became especially interested
in improving the performance of steam engines.
He published his research in a book called
Reflections on the Motive Power of Fire, in 1824.
And although his work was largely ignored, it
contained a revolutionary idea: a model for the
most efficient steam engine possible.
Today it’s known as the Carnot engine, and
the process by which it works is called the
Carnot Cycle.
The Carnot cycle is actually a hypothetical
process – it’s the most ideal cycle of changing
pressures and temperatures in a fluid.
And it’s ideal because it assumes there aren’t
any sources of waste, like friction or the conduction
of heat between different parts of an engine.
So we use this cycle as a standard to judge
the performance of heat engines.
The Carnot cycle consists of four processes,
all of which are reversible – two adiabatic and two
isothermal ones.
And it can take place in either a closed
or a steady-state system.
Let’s look at it in a closed system.
Let’s say we have a gas that’s contained
in an adiabatic piston-cylinder device.
As we start up our piston, the first process in the
Carnot cycle is called reversible isothermal expansion.
In this stage, the head of the cylinder starts in
close contact with an energy source, or reservoir,
at temperature TH.
This will transfer heat, which we’ll call
QH, to the gas.
As the energy source transfers heat, the gas
starts to expand slowly, which does work on
the surroundings.
As the gas expands, its initial temperature,
TH, tends to decrease.
But as soon as the temperature drops by a
very small, almost negligible amount,
some heat is transferred from the reservoir
to the gas, which warms it up, bringing it back
to its initial temperature.
That means that the temperature of the gas is
basically kept constant throughout the process, which
will continue until the piston reaches position 2.
At this point, we come to the second stage of
the Carnot cycle: reversible adiabatic expansion.
Here, we’ll make the process adiabatic by
replacing the reservoir with insulation.
This means that as the gas expands, it can
cool down, since it won’t be heated back up
by the reservoir anymore.
It will do this until its temperature drops
from TH to TL, which brings us to position 3.
Halfway there!
Now we just need to go in the opposite
direction as we begin the third stage of our cycle:
reversible isothermal compression.
So now let’s remove the insulation and bring
the cylinder into contact with an energy sink
at temperature TL.
This will cause the gas to transfer heat,
which we’ll call QL, to the reservoir.
Now, when some external force pushes the piston
inward, which does work on the gas, the gas will
compress and its temperature will tend to rise.
But as soon as the temperature rises by a
very tiny amount,
some heat is transferred from the gas to
the sink, which cools it down, causing the
temperature to drop back down to TL.
Now, you’ll notice that this is really similar
to what happened in the first stage!
The temperature of the gas will stay the same
throughout this process until the piston reaches
position 4.
Now we’re at the fourth stage of our cycle:
reversible adiabatic compression.
In this last stage, we’ll put the insulation
back on, making the process adiabatic again.
The gas will continue to slowly compress until its
temperature rises from TL to TH, which will complete
the cycle and bring us back to where we started.
And, since we’re back where we started,
we have a fully reversible cycle.
This makes the Carnot cycle the most
efficient cycle that we can have between two
different temperatures.
Now, even though we can’t actually achieve it in
reality, we can improve the efficiency of our cycles if
we try to model them more closely to Carnot’s design.
His work shows us that the efficiency of a heat engine
is only dependent on the temperatures of its heat
reservoirs, rather than the types of fluids that it uses.
As such, the maximum attainable efficiency of a heat
engine is equal to one minus the temperature of the cold
sink divided by the temperature of the heat reservoir.
Now, remember when I said that Carnot was
probably more brilliant than we’ll ever know?
Well, let me finish his story.
Soon after he published his work on the Carnot
cycle, he quit his job with the army and was left
without an income or any pension.
Diagnosed with “mania” and “general delirium,” he was
then sent to an asylum, where he contracted cholera,
which was sweeping through Paris at the time.
Carnot died at the age of 36.
And because all of his personal belongings were
considered to be contaminated, they were buried with
him, including all of his notebooks and papers.
So, the full scope of his work, and his genius,
has been lost to history.
Nonetheless, we do know that Carnot discovered the
limitation of efficiency, and his work has become
foundational to our understanding of wasted energy.
But, Carnot’s insights alone don’t fully explain
why we can never build the perfect engine.
We still need to understand another property – one
that wasn’t even put into words until a few decades
after Carnot came up with his cycle.
The great mind who gave us this property was
Rudolf Clausius.
Clausius was a German mathematician and physicist
who introduced the concept of entropy around 1850,
after he recognized the confusion between
Carnot’s work and the conservation of energy.
Entropy is the measure of a system’s thermal
energy per unit temperature that’s unavailable
for doing work.
It’s also the measure of the disorder, or
randomness, of a system.
Mathematically, if the entropy for a system
is 0, then we have a reversible process with no
change in entropy, like with a Carnot engine.
Any value over 0, and then the process is
irreversible and gains entropy.
So, every process results in either no change
in entropy or an increase in entropy.
It’s impossible to have an overall decrease
in entropy.
If you’re only looking at a system itself,
it’s possible to have a decrease in entropy.
But, and this is very important, the entropy of the system’s surroundings and the universe would have to increase by an amount greater than or equal to the loss of entropy inside the system.
Simply put, our universe always tends toward
disorder.
It’s just the way of all things.
In fact, scary as it may be, entropy and the
second law of thermodynamics actually predict
the end of the universe as we know it!
If everything is tending toward disorder, than the
logical conclusion is that all of the usable energy in
the universe may one day be converted to heat.
This event is known as the heat death of the universe
and, in addition to being a really wonderful band name,
it may one day be our fate.
I wouldn’t worry about it, though, because
while it makes sense in theory, many doubt
if it would actually happen.
And even if it did, it probably wouldn’t
happen for a really long time.
But whether or not entropy will cause the universe
|to end, it does make it impossible to create a perfect
engine with an output of 100% work energy.
We can try to get closer than we already are,
but no matter how inventive we get as engineers,
we always have to follow the rules of the
universe – even if it’s one that will lead to
our own doom.
So in today’s lesson, we learned about the
second law thermodynamics and how we came
to understand it.
We started by talking about the differences between
the first and second law of thermodynamics and how
the second law focuses on quality over quantity.
Then we talked about the Carnot cycle and
how it’s the most efficient form of a heat engine
with temperature differences.
We ended our lesson by going over entropy
and the randomness that can occur with a system.
I’ll see you next week, when we’ll learn
more about heat engines and how systems can
operate on a cycle.
Thank you to CuriosityStream for supporting
PBS Digital Studios.
CuriosityStream is a subscription streaming service that offers documentaries and non-fiction titles from a variety of filmmakers, including CuriosityStream originals.
For instance, CuriosityStream has a series called “Breakthrough” that’s a deeper look at some major recent developments in physics, astronomy and other sciences.
You can learn more at curiositystream.com/crashcourse and use the code crashcourse during the sign-up process.
Crash Course Engineering is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check out a
playlist of their amazing shows, like The Art
Assignment, Deep Look, and It’s Okay to Be Smart.
Crash Course is a Complexly production and
this episode was filmed in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney
Studio with the help of these wonderful people.
And our amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.